لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت التصعيد في الحرب
الاوكرانيه فكيف المنتشيه بقرار تسليمها
دبابات متطوره تواصل التحضير لمواجهه
موسكو الباحثه عن تعزيز قواتها تحسبا لحرب
الربيع المقبله تغيرات كثيره طرات على ارض
المعركه تتزامن مع اعلان موسكو الاستنجاد
بالجينيرال فاليري جراسي موف رئيس اركان
الجيوش والذي كان في الاساس مهندس العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه اعاده كلاسي موف الى
قياده العمليه لم تكن اعتباطيه في هذا
التوقيت بالذات وذلك قبل اشهر قليله من
احتمال دخول المعارك منعرج اخر مع نهايه
فصل الشتاء وذلك نقلا عن صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز معركه ستلعب فيها الدبابات دورا
حااسما خاصه بعد القرارات الغربيه الاخيره
بتسليم كاف حزمه من دبابات
الامريكي الالمانيه وهنا يمكن فهم سبب
استنجاد بقراسي موف ربما الذي يسمى في
الاوساط العسكريه الروسيه برجل الدبابات
فهي اختصاصه الاول فما هي الخطه التي ينوي
القائد الجديد للعمليه العسكريه اتباعها
في معركه الربيع دائما بحسب صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه فان غراسيمون سيعمد الى
الدفع بالروبوت القتاليه ماركر حيث سيقوم
بتسليم اربع روبوتات الى الايام وهي
روبوتات قتاليه دواره قادره على الدوران
حول نفسها
540 درجه في الثانيه واحده كما انها
مصحوبه بالنظام لتحديد الاهداف
الى جانب ذلك تقوم خطه جرسيموف الجديده
على الدفع بالقذائف المحموله في جميع
الجبهات وابرز هذه القذائف ار بي جي 7
والتي ستعمل على صد جميع انواع المدرعات
الخفيفه والثقيله على حبه سواء كما انه من
المرجح ان يقوم القائد الجديد بتسريع
عمليات حشد القوات الروسيه والتي شكلت
نقطه ضعف روسيه منذ بدايه الحرب
استخدام النووي